[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to our
program i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
that airs every week
you send us your questions we do the
research and if we can find an answer in
the bible we will be glad to answer your
question
just be patient because we received so
many questions that we're not able to
answer them all quickly
but eventually we will get to your
question and we will provide an answer
if the bible provides an answer
if you want to send us your questions
let me give you the email address
tv some tv.org
tv summtv.org
i have with me my dear friend c.a murray
and we're always so glad to have him
participate in the various programs of
secrets unsealed and some tv
thank you ca it's good to be here good
to study the word of god with you you
know i like to do that and uh studying
with you is a extra added blessing for
me so i'm glad to be here praise the
lord the feeling is mutual
[Laughter]
would you pray for us as we begin
shall we pray father god
again we praise you we thank you for the
word we thank you for the power
of the word we thank you that spiritual
things are spiritually discerned and
that we can come to your word with
earnestness and with sincerity and we
can go into your word and find truth for
our lives that makes us better citizens
of this world
as we prepare for the higher citizenship
which is in the world to come
thank you lord for this time thank you
for your spirit
in jesus name amen amen
well we have some very good questions
today ca
and i'll read the first one and then
maybe if you could
begin the process of answering this
question
my question is based on ezekiel chapter
but narrowing down to verse 20. and
here's the question
if the word of god says the soul that
sinneth
is the soul that shall die
and the son shall not bear the
iniquity of the father neither shall the
father bear the iniquity of the son
why then
was not only the entire human race
cursed on account of one man's sin
but why was nature cursed as well
so why did the curse fall only on human
uh not only on human beings but also on
nature i i think it this is first of all
it's an insightful question
what comes to my mind a couple of things
come to mind
the
statements in ezekiel that he references
talks to us about the individuality of
sin
your
righteousness
cannot save your son
your sins cannot condemn
your son
uh
my mother used to say every tub has to
rest on its own bottom in other words
everybody is responsible for for their
own sins so that's what's explained
there now
adam was the father of the human race
when adam sinned
this was no small thing pastor as you
well know
it was a it was a great thing and the
effects of his disobedience
uh
were felt through nature
god said in in in pronouncing the curse
that the ground is going to fight you
that the plants
are are are going to fight you thorns um
women are going to bear their children
in in pain and labor now so
it says the it be speaks the the
enormity of sin and and one of the
reasons we we have trouble with that is
because we've become so accustomed to
sin after 6 000 years we've become so so
comfortable with it that we don't see
the enormity of the break that sin
occasioned with god
god had a way of doing things and sin
said i want to do it this way not god's
way well that's a major
disturbance
in in the universe and so the the
consequences of that disturbance
were felt not only in man
but in animal and on planet earth all
creation
suffered the effects of sin right and
you know we need to distinguish between
guilt
and consequences
yes you know the text actually says
that
the son shall not bear the guilt of the
father
[Music]
so you know in other words the son is
not guilty of the father's sin correct
that's the point correct however all
nature suffered the consequences i mean
nature doesn't have the guilt of sin
it has the consequences consequences of
the sin of adam and there's a passage in
the book of romans maybe if you could
read that
romans chapter 8
is the
text i believe that provides a clear
answer to this particular question
romans chapter 8
and verses 18 through verse
it
explains the relationship between the
sin of adam and how it affected nature
for i consider
that the sufferings of this present time
are not worthy to be compared with the
glory which shall be revealed in us
for the earnest
expectation
of the creation eagerly waits for the
revealing of the sons of god
for the creation was subjected to
futility
not willingly but because of him who
subjected it in hope
because the creation itself
also will be delivered from the bondage
of corruption
into the glorious liberty of the
children of god
uh do you want twenty two also uh all
the way through 23. okay
for we know
that the whole creation groans and
labors with birth pangs together until
now and verse 23
not only that
but we also who have the first fruits of
the spirit even we ourselves grown
within ourselves
eagerly awaiting the adoption
uh the adoption the redemption of our
body
okay so so basically the gist of this
passage is
that
what happens to man happens to nature
adam sinned
and it impacted nature but when the sons
of god that means when when jesus
changed his mortal and corporal body
into the likeness of his glorious body
at that moment creation will be restored
also to its original condition
so it's speaking about the present
condition of man and the future
condition of man the present condition
of nature yes and the future condition
of nature in other words the condition
of nature
is contingent upon
the condition of man
man sins nature is futile yes man is
redeemed and glorified nature returns to
the way that it was i love it well said
in just backing a couple of chapters uh
to romans chapter 5 um i'm in 5 12
therefore just as through one man's sin
uh through one man sinned into the world
and death through sin and thus death
spread to all men because all have
sinned so it started with the infraction
of one man
uh but
the bible conversely says uh it was one
man who got us out of the fix right and
of course that was jesus christ one man
got us in one man got us out but the
effects are universal
that one man's sin
were universally felt and the redemption
that is given to us through one man's
glorification through jesus christ again
universally felt uh
here on earth yeah and only moral beings
can sin yes you know a dog does not sin
when a dog bites you
he's not held accountable i'm not i'm
not meaning to be irreverent yes in that
illustration yes uh the bottom line is
that the the texts in ezekiel is saying
that children
do not
inherit the guilt of the fathers yes
what they inherit is the consequences
of
of what the fathers were
uh to the third and fourth generation
the bible says but god's mercy is for
forever forever in the same commandment
and so
unfortunately nature is groaning
for the redemption of human beings
because then nature will be redeemed as
well as well as well well said well said
that's an interesting question and and
well put and we are thankful
for that this was um
uh
a good question so what's next
um let's see
is it uh it's the one on leviticus 19.
on leviticus 19. this is sabeso
calalucalaluca
writing to us from algeria and we thank
him for it hello
i've been reading the book of leviticus
and from the beginning i was getting the
idea of what ceremonial laws are
but when i reached chapter 19
it seems more like general law
i don't know if those laws
are still abiding or not because some of
them
are necessary to understand the ten
commandments in detail but some of them
are making me wonder which leads me to
ask this question
how are we how are we to filter some of
these laws which i think are somewhat
moral
laws or maybe ceremonial i'm not sure we
find about tattoos and many other and
and many of us take this and we believe
tattoos are not okay for a christian
but in the same verse we find uh about
man's haircut and beard should be
should it also be considered because if
not then why are we picking on part of
the verse and leaving others
i think we get the the idea he he really
wants us to break down
ceremonial law as opposed to
moral law
and the the ramifications of that um
let me say this and i'll give it to you
there when we talk about laws in the old
testament
we're talking about two
separate bodies of of law
one
placed by moses in the ark under the
mercy seat the other put in the side of
the ark
as mentioned in the book of deuteronomy
the
moral law is the basis
for the government of god
when we talk about moral laws we're
talking about the ten commandments
always applicable
always uh
in vogue dare i say
always uh applicable to to
mankind there were another group of laws
some ceremonial some civil some had to
do with the relationship between husband
and wife neighbor and neighbor that were
part of the a system of
of of working that god instituted so
that three million plus people depending
on what your number is could get along
for x number of years in the desert they
needed some regulatory assistance and
that's what those laws were to help some
were directly
uh looking forward to the coming of
christ
others were just civil laws
that helped me deal with you as a
neighbor to help you deal with me as a
neighbor um and uh they were part of
that second body of laws also yeah and
and some of those laws
uh still apply these days even though
they were
to keep society in harmony at that time
you know
dealing specifically with leviticus
chapter 19
there is an intermingling
of
of civil laws yes or israel uh maybe
even ceremonial laws
and
extensions of the moral law of the ten
commandments
you know sometimes we have to read the
bible with common sense
uh you know for example it says in
chapter 19 and verse 13 you shall not
cheat your neighbor well that's not
ceremonial law
cheating your neighbor is stealing from
your neighbor yes and so obviously that
still applies today it's not something
that was nailed to the cross
then you have verse 17 you shall not
hate your brother in your heart
so you know does that apply today of
course it does
uh you know you have you uh in verse 18
you shall not take vengeance nor bear
any grudge against the children of your
people obviously that's a universal
principle yes it's an extension of the
commandment
that speaks about loving your neighbor
as yourself yes however there are other
things that might be debatable for
example in verse 9 that's how it's going
okay go ahead
i was looking at that go ahead when you
reap the harvest of your land
you shall not wholly reap the corners of
your field nor shall you gather the
gleanings of your harvest so this is
something that is put in so that the
poor and destitute can be taken care of
it's just good business it's good sense
when you reap your land leave a little
around the edges so that people can come
in
who don't have and and and help
themselves also it's almost like a
welfare kind of a situation where the
people who are less fortunate are being
taken care of and not neglected and of
course we this has ramifications
later on we see this this uh being
played out in the in the genealogy of
jesus christ and we need to understand
that the bible many times speaks in
principles
uh you know
israel lived in an agricultural society
yes so it would be very easy to say when
you reap your harvest of your land you
shall not wholly reap the corners of
your field nor shall you gather gleans
of your harvest how would that apply to
us
who live in a technological society
today
is there a principle that would apply
that we're not supposed to use uh
everything that we earn for ourselves
but we're supposed to save a certain
portion to help those who are in need i
mean in terms of the principle yes yeah
i think the principle stands even to
today
the bible tells us that god gives us uh
things so that we can help we can help
others churches have darkest societies
they have other things where they they
they set things aside for other
individuals
individuals less fortunate we have addre
we have uh community services
so
we we ought not look out solely for our
own interests but look out for the
interests of those who in christ says
the poor you always have with you so you
always have opportunity to do good to
them and you should when opportunity
presents itself and not only dorcas you
know some people delegate the door well
i give to dorchester and let dorcas take
care of it you know we have an
individual responsibility yes to take of
of some of what we do not need
to share personally with individuals who
are in need in the church and in the
community in the community yeah if
you're spending all of whatever god
gives you on yourself
you're you're thinking only of yourself
you you of course the the ten percent
belong to the lord and then as an
offering that you give in in thanks and
return also but there are other things
you can do to share what god has blessed
you with uh
with with the wider community and as a
christian we ought to be willing to do
that and it ought to come from a heart
of love so i would suggest to sebesso as
he reads leviticus chapter 19
to look for the principles behind the
specific counsel that is given within
that cultural society yes
you know some of the specific things
might not apply today
but the principle behind those things
does apply
so look for the principles
behind
the specific council that's being given
here and then apply it to our time in
our culture well said the thing that
makes a principle a principle is that it
is applicable to all persons in all
times under all situations right uh
those principles stand fast and guard
the actions of all people in those
situations amen okay well we have
another question here this is a question
that comes up once in a while you know
when i travel
i usually do a q a
and
i've had this question come up a few
times
it
it comes from just a person
[Laughter]
which we don't know who that person is
but this is the question
would like for you to explain where all
the different ethnic groups came from
where and when did the people from china
and japan come to be
where and when did africans come to be
where and when did caucasians come to be
according to the bible
noah and his sons started to repopulate
the earth after the flood
how did eight people manage to produce
so many different types of
people so ca
share some words of wisdom with us
that's an interesting question we we
know that as man spread out over the
earth
he developed different characteristics
after the incident at the tower of babel
man was instructed by god
not to pull up in one place but to
spread out
now the thing about ethnic groups and
and different facial features and skin
tones and colors
you can go
from
my color
to your color
in just two generations
uh i have that in my own family
not several several times over right uh
all of my mother's brothers and my
mother is pretty much my color uh
married caucasians
they're all in canada
and so their their children
are
across between my color your color
but their children's children
uh
well brandon debbie two twins married
caucasians
their children look like you
so you can go from very dark to very
light in into generations and of course
as you move across the face of the earth
a lot of the adaptations skin color
these kind of things are are
in respect to where you are the
directness of the sun if you're up north
if you're down south so you can make
these changes um
suffice it to say the the potential for
all of that is in the human body god we
are fearful and wonderfully made if you
need to be darker to deal with the sun
you'll darken up right you need to be
lighter uh to deal with less sun
that will happen and it doesn't take
long it doesn't take generations upon
generations for those kinds of changes
to be made
and god allows mutations to take place
so that people can get can adapt to the
environment that you're in
you know i remember reading and i could
probably retrieve this
of some moths
that lived in a rural area
and suddenly it in turn it turned began
turning into an industrial area
and that entire population of moths all
of them were white
and when that when the industrial uh
environment came
the birds would see them and they would
eat them
and so
in a short period of time
they they mutated and all of the moths
became black
interesting to blend in with the
environment in fact i even i i read this
in the magazine these times that used to
be published in the adventist church and
its source there yeah god
makes it possible
for
a generation to adapt
to its
environment yes that shows the wisdom of
god it says wisdom of god you know for
example in uh in the heart of africa it
was called the white man's grave
right
but but you know people who had darker
pigmentation could subsist much easier
in that kind of environment yes it's not
that black is bad and white is bad it's
the fact that god gives us the ability
to adapt to our environment so that we
can survive well said well said yeah and
and he and he can do so
as you alluded to very quickly it
doesn't have to take millions of years
or a long evolutionary
just a couple generations and you can go
from very dark to very light or any of
the shades in between and god has placed
that within the human body to adapt for
survival sake and there's one thing that
we can be absolutely sure of
and that is that all of the ethnic
groups
all of the nations of the earth
come from the division at the tower of
babel yes
and they ultimately come from the three
sons of noah
you know in genesis chapter 10 we have
the table of nations
and the concluding verse verse 32
after mention mentioning the nations
that came from each of the sons of noah
yes it concludes by saying
these were the families of the sons of
noah
according to their generations
in their nations
and from these the nations were divided
on the earth after the flood after the
flood so black and yellow red and white
all are precious in his sight amen they
all come from the same source amen and
the sons of noah came from noah and noah
comes at the end of the genealogy that
comes from adam so we all come from adam
so there is a common ancestor his name
is adam right and you you know you know
once you start producing children and
generations you can you can populate
pretty fast um it doesn't again uh we
have
7 billion plus people on planet earth
now
and it all goes back you can deduce that
bring that down to one individual and
his wife amen
and and praise god for that and that's
the reason why
ca
racism cannot exist in the heart of a
true christian yes it's an impossibility
because in acts chapter 17 which i'm
sure you're well acquainted with i just
read a few verses here beginning verse
22 then paul stood in the midst of the
areopagus and said men of athens i
perceive that in all things you are very
religious
for as i was passing through and
considering the objects of your worship
i even found an altar with this
inscription yes to the unknown god
therefore the one whom you worship
without knowing
him i proclaim to you now comes the key
verses
god who made the world and everything in
it
since he is lord of heaven and earth
does not dwell in temples made with
hands yes nor is he worshipped with
men's hands as though he needed anything
since he gives
to all
life breath and all things and here is
the key and he has made from one blood
every nation of men to dwell on all the
face of the earth
and as determined there are
pre-appointed times and the boundaries
of their dwellings so
all he made from the same blood
if
people understood this
the strife in society over race would
suddenly disappear yes
but you know there's the people don't
first of all they don't believe in
creation they believe in evolution and
so it becomes much easier to be a racist
and to have conflict in society when
you're an evolutionist because it's a
survival of the fittest yes yeah so so
when you recognize that god created all
uh
you know of the same blood because we
all come from adam
then we're just all part of one great
family one great family yeah and that's
the way it should it should be
particularly in the church of god and
and of course every
denomination certainly i'm thinking
about protestant denominations back
through the history of
this country has had to deal with the
race issue
there is no denomination including our
own that has that has not had to wrestle
with that and to examine itself in the
light of texts like this which say we
all come from the hand of god amen or
from a common ancestor and we are under
all of these different shades brothers
and sisters incorrect amen you know we
have about a minute and a half left
can we just kind of digress a little bit
and have you talk a little bit about our
summit that's coming up
our summit is coming up on the last
weekend in
the month of october
the summit is a wonderful time when we
get together to discuss the things of
god art our theme this year is behold i
send you
elijah
and um
any number of sermons pastor will be
speaking i'll be speaking uh
jake alamo jay gallamore vicki griffin
vicky griffin and um uh i'm thinking of
the the doctor slash pastor nickname i'm
having a senior moment
eric
walsh
speaking
we're at tanaya lodge we're out in
nature we're out
in the redwoods in the forest it's a
beautiful place the food is fabulous
they do know how to do uh vegetarian
food the fellowship is great the time of
prayer activity this is something that
if you have not made your plans do so
it's getting late but the doors are
still open and there's room for plenty
more the last week in the month of
october we will be there and we'll be
looking for you to join us also we start
on a wednesday night and we end the
following sunday at noon it's an
unforgivable experience contact
secrets unsealed for information thank
you for joining us
we hope to see you next time on this
program i'd like to know
[Music]
you